so there is a clip we've talked about
this guy before uh he
is the man with the like crazy like
bugged out eyes with the private jets
yeah so this is a clip of him just like
looks like he's doing fun though
yeah laughing about uh bite and winning
and it looks
evil as [ __ ] dude i mean just by the
clip the media said what
the media said joe biden's present ha
him in the black dude competing
oh my god you gotta stand in the imaging
go into that
[Applause]
can you imagine being there in person
you're like bro i know what i
imagine we're just sitting there we like
do i'd love to go to one of those
what is it what is his style of church
uh [ __ ]
oh tell a evangelist i wouldn't have
said that
[ __ ] yeah oh dude come on you think
that's real that's not real
you know what he's doing he's he's he's
doing the con scheme that's what i'm
watching
a piece of [ __ ] televangelist you ever
seen when he got real creepy with the
reporter was like do you really need to
remember that yeah like you really
need to be private you need two private
jets he's like that's what the lord and
he's like staring at her
and he has like these piercing eyes when
he looks you don't feel sick
oh yeah you don't feel it right here
tell me you wouldn't be scared
hold on let's go to this tell me
wouldn't be terrified of this how are
you
and have a conversation we don't want to
we don't want to catch you off guard i
love inside edition
you got to get this now hey you listen
to me my wife thinks inside edition is
oh yeah oh my god he looks so [ __ ]
married
it takes a lot of money to do what we do
we have brought over a hundred let's see
this the latest figure just came he's so
nervous uh
122 million people to the lord jesus
christ this is a long-ass clip
i'm sure there's a condensed one over
here so creepy i mean i i
think you get the gist of it yeah i get
the gist of it
there he is with his friends face hell
yeah oh it's only three minutes
conversation you listen now
thank you lord help me just let me pray
[Laughter]
thank you give me the strength he's
trying to buy time
i know right i'm not missing that
dedication
in jerusalem look at his eyes without
the airplane that we have that i bought
from tyler
perry and i didn't pay anywhere tyler's
one of the greatest guy
he made it's he made that airplane so
cheap for me i couldn't help but buy it
[Laughter]
and don't you ever say i did oh [ __ ]
we wrestle not with flesh and blood
you're crazy if you don't think you
would hit her if there's no camera i
know right oh you explain what you're
doing i think it's crazy
yeah there it is he's a creepy might
want to chill out on those though you
know
that was almost like i don't give a [ __ ]
about the diet huh oh shut up
hey cut this part out no no need that
[ __ ] in there chin
fat shame them fast that's how you lose
weight
yeah that is true okay i won't eat
unless i ate that i won't eat a certain
amount later on today how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what just read a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like you look like a rottweiler
you gotta [ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son